Madame Mademoiselle Monsieur bonjour
Olivier je suis content de te retrouver
tu m'as manqué
nous allons vous faire une envie d'une
recette de temps en temps qui soit une
recette de fête et pourquoi une recette
de fête serait-elle chère oui on peut
poser la question
d'un fantastique pour les en croûte
farci alors pour ça il nous faut un
poulet moi j'ai pris un poulet Landé un
poulet jaune qui fait 1 kg 8 alors ce
poulet vous pouvez le faire désosser par
votre boucher ou par votre volailler ils
le font très gentiment
demandez poliment et puis alors moi par
contre je vais vous montrer comment on
désosse un poulet c'est très rapide
regardez le poulet il a encore son cou
il a été vidé et j'ai besoin de la peau
du cou ne me faites pas dire ce que je
n'ai pas dit Monsieur de rexin nous
enlevons le coup ça se fait beaucoup en
France depuis Marie-Antoinette et je
coupe le cou regardez-le en morceaux que
je mets dans une soucoupe même chose
avec les ailerons de ce poulet
car tous ces petits abats vont nous
servir pour la sauce
pour oui pour la sauce
voilà
et puis je coupe également de la même
façon les pâtes les pâtes ça va donner
un petit côté un peu gélatineux à la
sauce tu sais que les pâtes de d'animaux
en général sont un peu gélatines ah
maintenant regardez bien ce que je fais
avec ce poulet je le pose devant moi sur
le dos je casse ici les jointures
des cuisses excusez moi Madame voilà
je vais fondre le poulet s'il veut bien
pardon monsieur sur le dos surtout le
long de mon poulet et là regarde bien
c'est très simple à faire je vais suivre
tu vois il y a les côtes du poulet je
vais suivre sans oublier bien sûr ici le
saut lui laisse je vais suivre toute la
carcasse du poulet en m'appuyant avec la
lame du couteau sur la carcasse du
poulet jusqu'à ce tu vois ici j'ai la
jointure de la cuisse que nous avons
cassé tout à l'heure et je vais désosser
complètement c'est très facile à faire
regarder je vais désosser complètement
le poulet jusqu'au braicher et je vais
recommencer de l'autre côté il suffit de
suivre le pointillé regarde
nous finissons tu vois dans le V ici là
alors là il faut faire très attention
pour ne pas percer la chair du poulet
alors tu vois on n'est pas pressé il y a
des concours de désossage de poulet
l'homme le plus rapide du monde c'est
mon papa qui désosse un poulet en 58
secondes moins d'une minute
alors regardez la cuisse ici l'avant
cuisse tu vois c'est à dire le
la partie grasse de la cuisse tu racles
l'os de la même façon pour bien le
dégager et tu vas le couper ici à la
jointure il vient tout seul là tu vois
je vais faire la même chose avec l'os de
la deuxième cuisse et puis
le poulet sera prêt
voilà regarde l'os de la deuxième cuisse
et ce poulet nous allons pour l'instant
le reconstituer comme ça et le poser
sur notre plat ah regarde ici la
carcasse tous les os je les coupe en
morceaux
et tout ça va donner je le répéterai
jamais assez du goût à quoi
à la sauce qu'on va faire alors tu
allumes s'il te plaît le gaz tu poses le
grand plat dessus et dans ce grand plat
tu mets s'il te plaît une cuillère à
soupe d'huile d'arachide tu as une
cuillère en bois à côté de toi la voilà
et tu chauffes bien le plat et moi
pendant ce temps regarde ce que je fais
je coupe un oignon
en deux il était plus cher je le coupe
c'est fort en tranches fines
et je fais
la même chose
avec quoi oui
les mots qui sont les mêmes qu'en
français quand tu as compris ça tu
parles comme un livre comme dans la
mesure où vous pouvez pas regarde
carotte nous ne touche pas ça ne
chauffera pas plus vite parce que tu
mets les mains voilà carotte et oignons
alors je vais remettre ça dans ma petite
assiette et je vais mettre ça dans ton
grand plat où je le répète il y a une
cuillère à soupe d'huile d'arachide
j'ajoute regarde la carcasse du poulet
en morceaux les pâtes aussi les pâtes
aussi le coût toute la carcasse les
ailerons et je t'ajoute dedans un peu de
thym comme ça
voilà une feuille de laurier comme ça et
tu vas me bitoungner tout ça jusqu'à ce
que ça accroche un peu au fond mais en
attendant je te demande de me passer
s'il te plaît le
l'appareil miracle pose-le là on voit
que tu as été au salon
regarde ce que je fais j'ai devant moi
300 g de veau d'épaule de veau bien
dégraissés il faut pas qu'il y ait un
seul morceau de nerf ni de gras je coupe
cette épaule de veau
en petits morceaux comme ceci
je j'ajoute
dedans tu continues toi
j'ajoute dedans le foie du poulet que
nous avons soigneusement réservé et puis
qu'est-ce que je fais je vais fermer
l'appareil et
3 ça va
bon
j'arrête tu me passes s'il te plaît le
lait et un verre
alors
qu'est-ce que je fais je mets trois
belles tranches de pain de mie ou de
pain normal ou demi de peur ce que vous
avez chez vous les enfants dans un
saladier j'ajoute 3/4 c'est-à-dire 15 cl
de verre de lait et puis tout je vais
presser ça entre mes mains de façon à ce
que tout le lait tu me suit mon poulet
oh pardon
à ce que tout
pénètre bien dans le pain qu'est-ce que
j'ai fait également j'ai pris une
poignée de noisettes voilà des noisettes
je les ai mises dans un plat que j'ai là
et puis comme ça vous voyez et puis j'ai
mis ce plat au four
pour 10 minutes four maximum qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé les noisettes ont grillé
et quand les noisettes ont grillées je
les ai légèrement pilé comme ceci
tacatacata avec le petit truc bon mamie
de pain est trempé dans le lait ça va ça
attache docteur mais bien continue tout
ça attache meilleur c'est j'ajoute oui
car c'est ça qui va donner la couleur à
notre sauce arrête de bitonner une
seconde laisse ça tranquille ça te fera
pas de mal cette sautera pas dessus
regarde mes trois Franck demi de pain je
les ajoute là-dedans je vais casser
2 œufs sur le tout 1
2 je vais ajouter 50 g de beurre ramolli
au forum au lit ton température de la
pièce ça suffit je vais refermer
l'appareil
tous vos doigts je réduis encore
en pouvait mais il fallait c'était très
important commencer par la première
opération c'est-à-dire la chair de
volaille d'abord et ensuite seulement la
deuxième opération top ah regarde c'est
bien doré tu ajoutes s'il te plaît
dedans un verre de vin blanc vas-y un
verre plein c'est-à-dire 20 cl
voilà ébullition immédiate deux verres
c'est à dire 40 cl d'eau
1 2 regarde ta sauce qui prend la
couleur naturellement du doigt tu
ajoutes également trois pinces de sel
comme ceci pas trop parce qu'on aura
toujours le temps de recaler la sauce
après le poivre et tu vas laisser un
tout petit peu réduire pendant que moi
je finis ici la farce ah
j'ajoute maintenant ma poignée de
noisette je vous le répète que j'ai fait
griller au four et que j'ai un petit peu
pilier parce que le monde continue à se
piler toute seule j'ajoute 2 cuillères à
soupe de crème fraîche elle est pas bien
belle ma crème fraîche et la pas
supporter les seins de l'ail que les
enfants je refais je sale une cuillère à
café de sel fin
voilà je poivre ça va
l'obsédé du poivre bois de Boulogne
c'est moi
et à nouveau c'est parti pour une
nouvelle madame
j'ai un saladier qui est là tout va bien
la crépine je l'approche tu m'avertis
quand ça explose je prépare la crépine
le machin
voilà ça y est
on regarde
tout ça c'est ça
tu as été grandiose je vais enlever le
voile attention tiens-moi le truc parce
que moi je peux pas y aller tout seul
il est pas meilleur que les autres
je vais mettre cette superbe s'il est
bon non c'est que superbe chair
dans un saladier où est-ce que j'ai un
truc voilà et puis
tu peux m'enlever alors tu vois les
noisettes elles se sont un peu pilées
dedans ce qui fait que dans la chair qui
va être dans le poulet quand tu vas le
couper quand tu vas tu vas retrouver des
petits bouts de noisette qui ont un goût
merveille enlève-moi cet appareil
que je ne veux plus voir
la crépine vous savez tout ce que c'est
qu'une crépine c'est ce qu'on appelle
aussi la toilette du port cette petite
paroi fine que le charcutier vous vend
salé alors qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
regardez je l'ai fait tremper deux
heures dans de l'eau froide je l'ai
sauvé pas comme un torchon c'est fragile
et puis
je
l'ai maintenant étalé alors regardez
important
ça va là ça y est je prends le poulet
des osées
je le pose au milieu de ma crépine
j'ouvre ici la peau du cou
ah ouais
j'ouvre les cuisses du poulet en tout
bien tout honneur et
toute la chair
je commence par la mettre bien dans les
interstices c'est difficile à dire on y
arrive un des cuisses
je remplis maintenant
il faut que tous les éléments qui
composent la farce soient très froid
quand on fait la farce c'est important
pour qu'il ne se sépare pas sauf le
beurre le beurre lui mais la crème
fraîche très froide tout je crois que je
mets tout on va essayer et alors là je
l'ai pas dit Olivier c'est une surprise
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire mon camarade
regarde d'abord
un rendez-vous je replie soigneusement
mon poulet ça rentre pas
si ça va rentrer tu vois regarde ce que
je vais faire avec la peau du cou après
toi et qu'est-ce qui va faire mon
camarade d'accord ouais regardez ce que
j'ai devant moi j'ai eu un prix de
couture
et en commençant par la partie arrière
du poulet je vais le faire ça tient là
je commence
tu fais le point de croix le point de
chaînette je fais le point ce qui est
assez difficile à faire déjà tel quel et
là
Olivier je continue va continuer à
coudre il peut y mettre une petite heure
ce n'est pas grave mais moi ici j'éteins
mon bouillon qui est assez cuit hein
allez vas-y coucou on se retrouve quand
tu as presque terminé de coudre
voilà
ça y est il a fallu deux heures et demie
non c'est pas vrai alors tu veux que je
te coupe la marseillais tu as bien donc
remis je l'ai fait il était super la
peau tu vois comment on lance un bébé
quoi ni plus ni moins tu vois tout est
resté dedans
regardez au lit ça y est imaginez le
même en train de bravo des le soir au
coin du feu tac voilà alors maintenant
donc ce poulet est posé sur la crépine
qu'est-ce que je fais
Jean Mayotte délicatement le poulet dans
la crépine bien en la fermant bien
pourquoi mais parce que cette crépine va
d'une part protéger le poulet et lui
donner si tu veux un peu de gras pendant
la cuisson et également en cas qu'il y
est un petit trou dans la peau du poulet
ça ne sortira pas tu me passes le plat
qui est là où nous avons notre petite
sauce pose le comme ça regardez ce que
je fais je retourne le poulet du côté
non
fendu en deux quoi et je le pose
délicatement attends il faut faire un
lit tu vois où il est pas de morceaux
qui risquent de faire un trou dans le
costume du poulet voilà on glisse le
poulet
délicatoires alors ce qui est très
curieux c'est qu'à la cuisson qu'est-ce
qui va se passer Olivier grâce aux œufs
de la farce le poulet va gonfler et
reprendre sa forme de poulet hein bon
alors là
je vais prendre ce poulet et je j'ai
allumé le four le four est un thermostat
6 c'est-à-dire pas trop fort et on va
laisser cuire le poulet dans ce four
pendant une heure et quart en l'arrosant
toutes les 10 minutes je fais comme ce
gigelimété car jamais déjà notre reste
là-bas reste là-bas je vais sortir ce
poulet qui a une heure et quart de
cuisson thermostat 6 dans le four
le voilà regardez le referme le four
s'il te plaît
regardez-le tu vas s'il te plaît me
poser la casserole ici sur le feu et y
mettre dedans le
la passoire alors là regardez le poulet
et vous voyez la crépine ce qui s'est
passé elle a fondu on l'enlève
délicatement le patron maintenant on
fera le reste tout à l'heure et ce
poulet toujours très délicatement je le
pose sur une assiette j'ai mis un peu de
jus avec
et là tout ce jus du poulet
qui est gras
je vais le passer dans la passoire ici
tu y es
bien bien il faut bien laisser perdre là
le meilleur est toujours au fond et puis
je sais pas si on va pouvoir le montrer
oui oui on va pouvoir le montrer tiens
tu peux enlever ça Olivier vas-y te
brûle pas attends faut éteindre là je
vais enlever vous je sais pas si vous
voyez il y a une pellicule de graisse
vous la voyez au dessus qui est plus
jeune que la sauce vous enlevez cette
pellicule de graisse soigneusement et
vous obtenez une sauce superbe que vous
laissez de côté car là ce que je vais
vous dire est très important ce poulet
il faut le faire cuire le matin ou à
midi pour le manger le soir pourquoi
quand il est cuit il faut qu'il
refroidisse naturellement or pour qu'il
refroidisse naturellement il va falloir
deux trois ou quatre heures il va
continuer de gonfler tu vois il va y
avoir osmose avec la farce à l'intérieur
et il ne faut pas le mettre au
réfrigérateur car sur le métier
réfrigérateur quand on le mettrait dans
la pâte feuilletée après elle serait
trop froide tu vois le temps de le cuire
après au four alors vous le laissez si
vous en avez un garde-manger tu sais
c'est bien garde à manger avec des
grillages dedans ou alors quand le four
est froid dans le four et puis vos
invités arrivent mon Dieu bonjour madame
parce que normalement le chat doit le
manger à ce moment-là
pas manger le Poulet vous êtes prêts la
pâte feuilletée est étalée sur une sur
le truc là sur la devant nous et on se
retrouve nous avec la pâte feuilletée
étalée devant nous en 2 secondes
et bien les invités sont là mon Dieu mon
Dieu qu'est-ce qui va se passer ce qu'on
va y arriver oui oui alors on a étalé
notre pâte feuilletée surgelés en
seconde et deux plates tu vois on les a
relié les unes aux autres avec un peu
d'eau
et regardez le poulet refroidi
complètement froid là ici il y a les
petites ficelles on les laisse et
regarde ce que je fais je vais le poser
retourner c'est à dire le côté où il y a
pas de couture sur ce qui va être le
dessus après quand on va mettre au four
ah c'est trop grand ça bravo c'est trop
grand ça va faire tout à l'heure dedans
tu vas le voir tu vas faire de belles
bandes je te les mets déjà de côté et là
ici c'est un peu trop grand là aussi
regarde ici maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on
fait je fais une fente là claque comme
ça une fente là claque comme ça et
maintenant
je retiens j'enlève un peu le surplus de
farine je replie
le poulet dans le feuilletage ici là
maintenant je vais le souder un peu avec
de l'eau oui un peu d'eau oui non dur
que ce que je raccorde l'eau bouge pas
je sais plus où j'avais la tête je
pensais une recette économique je vais
battre
on a les moyens Antenne 2 tu fais la
soudure à l'oeuf je fais la soudure je
bats légèrement un oeuf je trempe un
pinceau dedans je commence à souder je
vais replier largement comme ceci je
vais souder tout le dessous tu vois
comme il va toucher le fond du de la
plaque du four il faut qu'il soit très
largement
replié tu vois comme ceci dessus et là
maintenant regarde
c'est un petit encore une fois le petit
bébé qu'on en Mayotte là moi dans la
couture ça va mais toi pour le longer
les lardons c'est pas mal non plus là
ici je vais attends je vais ici replacer
autour de ma cuisse comme ceci oh
je suis pas très doué pour ça ma forme
on y arrive quand même et puis là
regarde ce que je vais faire la plaque
du four s'il te plaît où est-elle la
plaque du four que j'ai légèrement
beurré
là le poulet on va le retourner sur la
plaque du four on va bien selon mayoter
ici
aux cuisses
comme ceci là un petit coup encore une
fois de sucre là
tu vas s'il te plaît me tailler des
bandes de
des bandes regarde je t'en fais une pour
faire joli pour faire joli je te fais la
longueur de la bande comme ça tu vas me
tailler là dedans des bandes
et là il me reste simplement
à passer mon poulet
haut à 9 battus
dépêche-toi dépêche-toi comme ceci alors
le dessus du poulet c'est ce qui risque
enfin le dessus du feuilletage c'est ce
qui risque de craquer à la cuisson c'est
pour ça que nous allons le soutenir avec
des bandes de feuilletage des
bandelettes comme comme tout en Camon tu
vas voir on pourrait d'ailleurs appeler
ça le poulet farci at the toutan
une utilité alors moi j'ai dit que
c'était pour faire joli non c'est pour
c'est joli d'abord
je prends mes bandes là comme ceci et je
les pose déjà sur le un peu fine à
celle-là quand même tu m'as fait
quelques unes encore s'il te plaît un
peu plus large un peu plus large oui
on a les moyens
tu en fais ça y est voilà
la brusquement c'est lui qui aura ça il
sera gâté encore ça suffit ça suffit là
comme ceci et là maintenant encore un
petit coup tu peux tout m'enlever s'il
te plaît commencer à me nettoyer ça
serait fantastique que si tu pouvais
donner un petit coup après avec l'éponge
qui est à côté de toi et là
ce poulet il est prêt à la farine
il est prêt enfourner le four est
préchauffé thermostat 7 ok je vais
mettre ce poulet tel quel au four
préchauffé thermostat 7 pour plus par
terre pour 30 minutes
j'en ai un au four je vais le chercher
pendant que mon camarade fini de
nettoyer
ça y est tu es prêt ça y est ça y est
vas-y ok j'arrive
et vous allez laisser bouillir ce Porto
avec la sauce pour lui enlever son goût
de Porto
une minute une minute et demi juste le
temps que je vous rappelle les
proportions du poulet farci en croûte
regarde
pour le poulet farci en croûte il nous a
fallu un poulet de 1 kg 8 une cuillère à
soupe d'huile la farce était composée de
300 g d'épaule de vaux bien dégraissées
bien d'énervé trois grosses tranches de
pain de mie deux œufs
3/4 de verre c'est-à-dire 15 cl de lait
2 cuillères à soupe de crème fraîche 50
g de beurre ramolli une poignée de
noisette qu'on a fait griller au four et
puis qu'on a un peu écrasé une belle
crépine du sel et du poivre et puis pour
le jus il nous a fallu un oignon une
carotte les abats du poulet tu sais
qu'on a mis tout ça au fond du plat le
thym du laurier du sel du poivre un
verre c'est-à-dire 20 cl de vin blanc 2
verres c'est à dire 40 centilitres d'eau
la croûte était faite de pâte feuilletée
qu'on a acheté surgelés et puis de 9
battus pour doré et la sauce était faite
avec 50 g de beurre mou on va le
rajouter à l'instant
une cuillère à café de farine qu'on va
rajouter à l'instant et un demi verre
c'est-à-dire 10 cl de porto
ben voilà regarde ça bouillie juste le
temps de lire les proportions regarde
une cuillère bien pleine à café de
farine tu mélanges ça tu écrases
ensemble et tu verse dans la sauce qui
va se lier et tu mélanges avec le fouet
et moi pendant ce temps
le voilà
j'enlève j'ai pas une torchon si
j'enlève la plaque chaude
et là je vais le couper le poulet
mélange avec ton fouet je vais le couper
je vais le couper
j'y vais
regardez-moi ça
ouh là là je veux pas faire de ça va
est-ce que ta sauce se lit naturellement
très vite tu la verse dans le moi je
veux vous présenter oh là là là tu la
verse dans la petite sorcière
regardez-moi ce poulet je te coupe une
tranche de poulet qui me passe s'il te
plaît ton assiette
regardez la tranche là la superbe
tranche tu vois les noisettes dedans tu
vois la couleur de la farce je pose
l'autre ici comme ça moi j'ai même pas
le temps de me servir donc je vais
mettre un peu de temps
un peu de Grosso voilà que c'est beau
tout ça je vais te mettre un tout petit
peu de sauce sur ton poulet regarde si
elle est belle comme ceci oh tu vas
partir avec les deux assiettes et là
avec ton assiette et la sauce voilà
je pars avec le poulet
et on va quand même boire un coup avant
nous dire on va faire moi avoir vite
vite moi ce superbe poulet je te le
prête non non
dernière chose on vous dit au revoir
pour faire ce poulet je voulais pas dire
il faut un poulet Label Rouge fermier ne
prenez pas n'importe quel poulet bon
appétit prenez un week-end
est-ce qu'il est bon mais maintenant
prochaine pour une autre émission
regardez regarde cette beauté de
l'intérieur de tous je voudrais bien ici
quand même écouter un tout petit peu je
sais pas si je vais y aller tu me
permets que je goûte aussi voilà
[Musique]